Bon la Casa de Papel, on aime ou on
n'aime pas mais il y a plein de petites
choses dans les images qu'on va pouvoir
regarder y a plein de petites subtilités
que vous n'avez peut-être pas vu et qu'on
va regarder juste après l'intro
Si senor, c'est tout ce que je sait dire en espagnol.
Et salut à tous les amis c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique-moi
encore et aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser
à la série netflix la casa de papel et si vous l'avez pas encore
regardée
franchement je vous invite à aller faire
un petit tour ça vaut le détour c'est
plutôt sympa parce que si vous faites de
la vidéo il y a plein de choses qu'on
peut reproduire qui sont très très
simples et auxquelles on pense pas forcément.
Bon et puis comme je veux éviter de me
faire striker et on va travailler sur des
captures d'écran plutôt que sur les
vidéos elle-mêmes. Alors dans ce que je
vais vous dire il y a des règles plutôt
basiques que vous connaissez peut-être
sûrement mais il y a des petites
subtilités assez sympa. Mais sans plus
attendre allons regarder ces fameuses
images. Première chose assez flagrante
et assez classique c'est la fameuse
règle des tiers
Alors vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu
parler vous la mettez peut-être déjà en
pratique cette fameuse règle des tiers
elle consiste à diviser notre écran en
neuf parties égales, comme ça. Cette règle
elle permet de créer un effet esthétique
ou de diriger le regard du spectateur
vers un endroit particulier. Souvent on
mettra les personnages principaux sur
une de ses lignes imaginaires ou on
divisera le cadre en fonction de ces
lignes dans la Casa de Papel
s'est très souvent utilisé pour diviser
l'espace comme dans ce plan par exemple
on a vraiment trois parties bien
distinctes séparées par des éléments
bien rectilignes. On peut diviser en 3
bien sûr mais on peut faire un tiers 2/3
comme dans ce passage où on voit tokyo
marcher sur la route avec la route qui
prend deux tiers de l'espace et une
ligne bien définie pour le ciel et où on
la voit marcher et s'éloigner petit à
petit. J'ai foutu un postillon, j'ai
réussi à foutre un postillon sur
l'objectif. Deuxième
point que nous allons aborder celle
asymétrique
dans cette série on voit quand même bien
que le réalisateur est un sacré fans de
plantes symétrique pas autant que wes
anderson si vous connaissez pas aller
faire un tour
ça vaut le coup aussi niveau 6 maîtrise
juste barjots comme dans ce plan ou
franchement l'esthétisme claque sa race
et pour le coup ça annule complètement
la règle des tiers mais franchement ça
claque quand même parce que qui dit
symétrie ben 10 coupé en deux soit un
vertical soit en horizontal et là il y
en a un pack sont deux plaintes
symétrique avec des petits mouvements de
caméra de travelling avant arrière sur
les côtés c'est juste moi j'adore et
souvent on va se retrouver avec des
plans ou en plus de ça on va avoir de
superbes lignes de fuite c'est à dire
des trucs à peu près comme ça qu'ils
vont diriger directement l'oeil du
spectateur sur un endroit bien précis
comme dans ce plan que je trouve juste
énorme avec la mitraillette où on a une
symétrie cpt quasi parfaite des lignes
de fuite juste énorme qui envoie juste
au milieu du plan pour qu'on voit bien
bas la mitrailleuse à là pour le coup on
met l'accent dessus ça donne un effet
encore plus dramatique à la scène et là
vous le voyez pas parce qu'un mouvement
de caméra mais dans ce passage il ya un
travelling arrière qui va permettre de
découvrir la symétrie et les personnages
qui sont deux à gauche et à droite de la
mitraillette et vraiment niveau
esthétique moi ça m'a juste mais éclatée
quoi j'ai trouvé ça énorme troisième
petits secrets qui moi me plaît
énormément dans ces images et dans la
composition c'est le cadre dans le cadre
on retrouve très souvent ça en photo
mais ça marche très très bien en vidéo
et pour illustrer ce que je vais vous
dire je vais vous montrer cette image
précisément qui est vraiment juste
superbe
là on se retrouve avec le cadre de notre
prise de vue un petit rectangulaire et à
l'intérieur de ce cadre on a cette porte
de coffre fort qui est ronde et qui va
venir faire un cadre dans le cadre tel
le voisin qui écoutent bellaciao est
énorme
et là on a un plan qui est juste superbe
qui est pas très compliqué qui n'est pas
ultra recherché ultra fond mais qui
vient nous donner cette sensation ici de
géométrie de symétrie de satisfaction de
deux plans bien bien bien composer un
mois je kiffe
enfin on va parler des points de force
les points de force se sentent tout
simplement les intersections des lignes
créées par la règle des tiers
l'idée ici c'est de placer des éléments
importants de la scène sur ces points
précis pour assister pour guider le
regard du spectateur est ici c'est
flagrant c'est à dire que sur un de ses
points de force on a le visage de cette
demoiselle qui s'appelle comment déjà
je sais plus son nom allison ici on a un
des points qui est sur le visage
d'alison et l'autre point qui est sûr le
pistolet qui est braquée sur son visage
donc là on peut pas faire plus obvious
en gros le réalisateur et que vous
montrez lit elle flingue il ya la
tranche ça craint et là c'est un exemple
parmi d'autres mais là pour le coup on
le retrouve énormément dans toute la
série à chaque fois qu'il ya un dialogue
vraiment les points de force c'est super
important la règle des tiers c'est
utiliser systématiquement ya pas un plan
qui a coté là dessus c'est vraiment
limite légale au nom maniaque du la
règle des tiers
enfin non parce qu'on arrive justement
sur le dernier point où on va parler il
te casser les règles
et là pour le coup le mec il les casses
pas mal quand même donc c'est bien beau
la règle des tiers les points de force
la symétrie
mais ça peut être sympa de s'en
affranchir pour aller encore plus loin
et créer des images auxquelles on
s'attendrait pas forcément mais parce
que dans le générique si vous regardez
la fin la dernière image du générique on
n'a pas une zone divisé en trois mais
bien en deux on a le titre sur la partie
supérieure et on a la maquette en papier
du bâtiment dans la partie inférieure
donc layani symétrie ni règle des tiers
ni points de force ni quoi que ce soit
y'a pas de cadres dans le cadre
n'empêche que le plan il est classe puis
on arrive sur mon plan préférés de la
série le truc que j'ai trouvé juste trop
beau pas forcément ultra original mais
trop beau c'est celui là
donc là vous me direz ok alors y'a pas
de symétrie c'est juste coupé en deux il
n'y a pas de règle des tiers il n'y a
pas de points de force y a rien du tout
mais si on regarde le plan qui vient
juste après ben on se rend compte qu'on
a le même plan complètement à l'envers
avec des couleurs différentes et le type
a fait une symétrie sur deux plans
premier plan ok très bien ce we bought
uk et on arrive sur le deuxième plan
oula c'est l'exact opposé du premier
puisque on a les gens qui sont à
l'intérieur de la fabrique de monnaie et
le professeur qui est à l'extérieur donc
là en terme d'interprétation on est
vraiment sûr voilà c'est l'intérieur
l'extérieur c'est le miroir c'est
l'opposé et là pour le coup ça n'a pas
été fait sur un seul plan mais ces deux
plans qui vont ensemble et là quand je
les ai vus le plein j'avais un petit peu
de bave qui coule et ça c'est beau donc
voila vous l'avez compris j'ai beaucoup
aimé esthétiquement la casse à des papes
elle j'ai bien aimé le scénario si
c'était vraiment une série qui était qui
était très intéressante même s'il ya des
petits trucs un peu gros que la fin elle
est bon comme lé même s'ils veulent
faire une saison 3 est là juste non si
je ne sais pas possible du n'en faites
pas ça s'il vous plaît pas ça et bien
sûr que cette technique n'est pas
l'apanage de las casas des papes est là
on la retrouve dans beaucoup de films
beaucoup de séries mais moi j'ai trouvé
dans cette série s'était énormément
utilisé c'était très bien utiliser très
esthétique vraiment à mener de façon
super bien dosé si on avait nos séries
françaises qui faisaient un petit peu la
même chose ça pourrait être pas mal
et donc ça montre bien une chose c'est
le point que je voulais vous démontrer
dans cette vidéo c'est que pour
apprendre à composer et à faire de
de bons plans c'est vachement
intéressant de regarder beaucoup de
films beaucoup de séries et de
s'attarder un petit peu de mettre sa
casquette de vider assez de regarder
tient ou est-ce qui s'est placé une
cadreur à ce moment là pourquoi il a
pris comme ça tient ce plan il est super
jolie je vais essayer de refaire un truc
un peu dans le même style dans ma
prochaine vidéo
et puis ça donne une excuse pour se
vautrer dans le canapé à regarder
netflix tout une autre chaîne au cs ou
amazon ou ce que vous voulez voir les
amis c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu si
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mettre
l'habituel coup de blaster sur le pouce
en l'air qui se situe juste en dessous
de cette vidéo abonnez vous pour ne rien
rater de la suite moi je vous dis rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
Oh bella ciao bella ciao, bella ciao ciao ciao...